welcome everyone
this is Rob Sanders from simply learned
and today we're going to talk about
MailChimp so we're gonna go through the
features and benefits of using MailChimp
as your email content platform so buckle
up and let's get started with MailChimp
so the first thing you need to do is
sign up for an account with MailChimp
and that's simply just providing an
email address and ID and a password and
I recommend when you actually sign up
for an account you sign up with a free
plan first and let's take a look at what
the feature plan features are for
MailChimp
so I'm recommending the free plan but
when you actually sign up you have the
option to actually pay for a plan so you
have the essential the standard the
premium or the free and so I recommend
you go with the free version first it's
like buying a car you want to test drive
it out see if you like it see if you
like the features and benefits and you
can see here that with the free plan you
get a lot of features and benefits so
you get all the basics for businesses
that are just getting started so if
you're just getting started with email
marketing I would recommend the free
plan here because you have a 2,000
contact maximum so that means you can
send out an email to your 2,000
recipients free of charge
so not a bad deal for businesses who are
starting out I mean if you are prepared
you've used MailChimp before then go
ahead and sign up for one of the paid
versions each version has a different
set of standards a different set of
features and benefits from the essential
all the way up to the premium where
you're gonna get you know vans features
and more customization but that's $299 a
month so if you're not prepared to pay
that amount then my recommendation start
with that free plan now when you
actually do set up your account you're
just gonna again provide a ID email
address and password you're going to go
through a couple of steps and one of
these steps that I would recommend you
do right away is connect to your
Facebook and Twitter accounts so if you
already have a Facebook and Twitter
account very simple
all you're doing is authorizing
MailChimp to connect the account and the
reason for that is when you actually
connect your Twitter Facebook account
you'll be able to then you know share
content on those platforms and MailChimp
will do that for you automatically
okay so here you're just asking it to
more or less interact with the platform
social platform and I recommended doing
that as you're going through the setup
process very simple to do if you're
already logged into your Twitter
Facebook account all you need to do is
click on the plus button as you go
through the setup wizard and authorize
MailChimp to access your Twitter or
Facebook account here you can see what
MailChimp's gonna be able to do they're
gonna be able to read tweets from your
timeline post tweets for you on your
behalf if you want them to if you want
them to
you're gonna allow MailChimp to see
create and manage your advertising data
including the campaigns and audiences
and the reason for this is you may you
know want to integrate your email
marketing efforts with your social media
efforts and the great thing about
MailChimp is hey look if you want to
post content on these platforms you'll
be able to if you want to leverage other
benefits from Facebook and Twitter and
integrate them with MailChimp you'll be
able to so having these two platforms in
the case of Facebook and Twitter talk to
MailChimp is a positive because then
you'll be able to do a little bit more
get your message out there a little bit
more so I highly recommend you take this
as a necessary step when you're going
through the setup now it's optional you
don't have to but I recommend it now
when you're actually setting up your
account you're gonna be asked to you
know design a template okay so you could
pick a template just by to fall you
could pick one just to get the account
going but you can always go back and add
or change out the template so here you
can see I'm in the setup wizard but I
arbitrarily just chose a template I can
go back and choose some of the templates
that are available to me now I can you
create your own template if you want to
okay so you just click create template
and you'll be you asked to choose kind
of a your template that you can pretty
much change
customize so if you're thinking about
sending out an email with an
announcement then that's the type of
template you want to choose and so here
now you can see we have a logo we can
change the announcement here we can add
photos etc so if I want to add my logo
I'm just gonna go up to this top portion
here click the little pencil icon
that'll allow me to edit here you can
see it's the fault logo I don't really
have a logo so I can say replace it I
can also link to it and here you can see
in the content studio of MailChimp
I don't have any images to choose from
so I'm gonna go ahead and upload one and
I'm gonna go ahead and upload my logo
that I've had on my desktop ok so it's
gonna upload and now I can select that
and insert it so now I have my logo as
part of my template here and you can
also see you can add some styling here
to this Hopf header part so I can add a
nice border around that okay so I can
align it center
I can go edge to edge okay so I can
customize the image in this particular
template here so I'm just gonna click
Save and close now I'm ready to move on
to the next part which is just click on
edit I want to make an announcement
okay share your big news ok we're having
a launch party so here you can see again
just in this template these
quote-unquote announcement template I'm
able to just make changes to each
section now I'm in the section of the
announcement part where I can now
customize the text and you can see I can
you bold it you know I can choose a
different fonts go aerial I could choose
the size you can make it smaller larger
pretty easy to use I could again style
it with different color and so I can
make multiple columns here if I want to
so there's a lot you can do just in this
one section as well so let's go ahead
and just do one more thing here let's
maybe call it or something I mean you
can see I can add a link let's go ahead
and make it blue that's the background
so I want to change the background so
I'm just gonna kick ctrl Z I'll change
the color the font itself there you go
very simple and easy to use now I can
add photos here if I want to so let's go
ahead and edit this bottom part here so
I'm gonna click again the Edit icon okay
so here you can see I have three images
in the template I'm gonna go ahead and
add to that so here I can go ahead and
upload some files so I have some files
waiting for me on my desktop I'm just
gonna go ahead and add them and upload
them to the content studio and now that
I've uploaded them I can select one of
them to insert okay now I'm gonna go
here insert the second one and now I'm
gonna grab the third one and insert that
in its place here you can see now I can
go ahead and you know style each one of
these if I want to okay I can add a
border again okay I can go ahead and do
rounded corners okay settings you can
see how I can set it up this so they're
all vertical I can do this so I have a
lot of flexibility and what I add to
these particular you know templates okay
this is again just the announcement
template and so now I'm gonna click Save
and close and here you can see I can add
some other things to it if I wanted to I
can play around with the design and
header and once I'm done really I'm
happy with my email I can just close it
out and I'm done so what I could do now
is when you're done with this template
you can just preview and test it so I
could send a test email or enter preview
mode so if I enter premium and this is
what the template I chose is gonna look
like if I happen to send it out okay so
this is what it looks like I'm desktop
this is what it looks like a mobile and
if I go in box preview I'll need to
upgrade my account because I'm on the
free version so but I can certainly see
what it looks like on mobile on desktop
so I'm just gonna click out of that and
this is a template and so I can go back
and
this anytime I want so when I'm done I'm
just gonna go ahead and click the
MailChimp icon in the upper left it's
gonna ask me to name my template so I'm
going to name this the announcement
template I'm going to click Save and now
it's in my templates so I'm free to use
this template
anytime I'm ready to send an email okay
and again I can you saw how easy it was
to make a change in the template itself
so when I'm ready to use the template I
can just go ahead and grab it and again
I can go ahead and style it and design
it any way I want so you have different
sections of the page that you can style
and here you got you know mobile style
designs if you wanted to now if you
wanted to in the template if I want to
like duplicate the whole blog I can
duplicate that whole block and you can
see it just copied it or I can just get
rid of it so very easily to use WYSIWYG
if you will or interface it allows the
you know MailChimp allows from some easy
you know functionality easy features to
go ahead and manipulate and change to
your liking okay so again I'm working
with a template here so anytime we're
ready to use that template for an email
I can go in and start using it okay and
if I go to templates again I'm gonna
find my template here I can always edit
it I can always share it I can always
preview it I can replicate it and that's
the important thing so if I wrap a clay
in it I'm basically creating a copy of
it okay so I just created a copy so now
if I wanted to create a or change the
copy of it I can do that so if I don't
like this whole block I can just delete
it and now that I'm done I can rename
this I'm just cuz they announced the
template b2 so now it's been renamed and
now I have two templates just simply by
choosing one and replicating it again if
I go back to templates here here I go I
have my two templates and I can store
these in a folder so I'm gonna add a
folder I'm going to call it
announcements and I'm gonna add the
folder and that's it so now I can store
these in the folder so you can organize
all your templates in different folders
if you want to so I'm going to take
these two templates here move them to my
announcements folder and there you go
they're in the announcements folder so
if you're going to create multiple
templates
I would recommend you go ahead and
organize it create folders you know and
set up as many folders as you want and
need it's because you're going to
probably have different templates for
different occasions
depends on what type of email you're
sending out so I just chose arbitrarily
an announcement type email so now if I
go back to create templates okay you can
see again let's go through some of these
others again I just shows make an
announcement you can tell a story
follow-up educate you've got all sorts
of different templates that you could
choose all sorts and here you got some
themes so you can even go with a theme
if you wanted to so for example if
you're selling products let's just say
I'm a boutique store let's just choose
this boutique template if I choose this
here is my themed template and so now
just like the other template I was
working in I can go ahead and edit this
here you can see at the top I got the
middle section you know I got all these
different sections then I can now go
ahead and add it so just about really
it's about choosing the theme template
that works best for you and feel free to
you know try these different templates
out and see what works best for you so
here you can add in certain things like
you know social share so if I just drag
and drop I can add in a social share
image card so a lot of these themes are
very flexible in what you can do terms
the design in terms of the content so
again if you go back and I'm gonna
cancel and not save this templates save
it would call critique we may use it
again in the future so I'm gonna go
ahead and click Save and now it's a
template it's gonna be located in
templates and again if you always want
to access templates just go to templates
you'll see the templates that you
already have created and edited so you
can edit them always just by clicking
the edit button now that's again if you
want to create a new template just
create click on the create new template
call to action again you got themes
you've got layouts or you can even
create your own from scratch you can
import another template that you created
in another email marketing platform or
you can do simply just do everything
from scratch and HTML so you have three
different options here
themes and creating a template on your
own okay and that's either by importing
or by creating it from scratch okay my
recommendation I like some of the
layouts that MailChimp has you can see a
lot of flexibility here and when you
actually choose one again you're in full
control of how to design and message it
so you're a full control of that so if
you just wanted again tell a story I'm
gonna select this template here okay now
I'm on the free version so keep in mind
with the free version I don't have
access to all the templates so here I
get an upgrade to use this one but for
example if I don't see the message up
Grady use then I'm free to grab it so
you can see the one column I'm pretty
used so I'm just gonna select that and
now I have this template available to me
so again I'm free to edit this one as I
see fit I mean I can go ahead and again
drop in any one of these elements that
are available to me here I'm gonna drop
in my social block okay so here you can
see I can now customize my social block
if I want to add in another platform I
can do that social media platform click
Save and close
so you can see they're very customizable
all of these themes and layouts are very
customizable and again when you're done
it's just a matter of you can preview it
or test it you can enter preview mode or
you can send yourself a test email okay
if you send yourself a test email you
can actually see how it looks when it
comes in so let's go ahead and do that
here so I'm just gonna send myself a
test email and the email has been sent
so let's go check our inbox so here is
the email that I just created from the
theme you can see here all I did simply
when I edited I just dropped in my
social block in here so this is what the
email looks like and the great thing
about MailChimp is they have an option
that you can view the email in a browser
if you can't or you know don't want to
look at it and you're in this case I'm
looking at Gmail so you can always or
recipients can always view the email in
a browser versus the email client that
they're using and specific now when it
comes to completing your profile on
MailChimp you're going to need an
audience to send these emails to
and so when you click on audience here
if you don't have an audience already
imported into MailChimp you're gonna be
asked to import so you can see I already
have one contact that contacts me
because I added my email address on that
test email so milk sham is smart enough
to say okay we don't have this email
address in our contact list so we're
going to add them so here we can see we
can manage our audience so we can add
subscribers we can import contacts we
can have signup forms and we can manage
our contacts so if we import our
contacts if I click on import here I'm
going to be asked to import either from
a CSV or copy and paste or I can just go
ahead and integrate it so if I choose
for example any one of these then it's
gonna pull in the context I have there
and so it's up to you how you import
your contacts now the whole point of
contacts is you want to probably or
really not probably it's the best
practice to actually create different
lists so that you can use different
audience lists with different emails and
so here you can see you have one email
address I can again import contacts or I
can add them individually so I can ask
subscribers here ok that's another
option that's the slower option my
recommendation be import them but when
you import make sure you you're
importing lists that have some
commonality so you can manage those
lists so if you have one list that or
say you know clients who have never
purchased then you want to create a list
for them if you have clients who have
purchased separate those out ok so
that's the way I would go about it now
if you're trying to build a list
MailChimp has what they call signup
forms so you have different forms that
you can embed and/or have as a pop-up
and when people add their email address
to that form then it's automatically
going to get added to your MailChimp
account so that's a great feature
MailChimp that allows you to you know
build out your audience just by using
one of their forms so again we have a
subscriber pop-up you've probably seen
some of these and some of the websites
you've gone to so you can customize it
and if you want somebody to subscribe to
your newsletter for example all you need
to do is enter in their email address
and click to subscribe okay that's the
pop-up version now again you have the
opportunity to you know use other forms
as well so you've got a form builder
here or an embedded form okay or you can
integrate the form okay so if I click
form integrations here I can use wufu or
Squarespace I can integrate with them if
we go back to signup forms but use form
builder here I have a signup form and
then I can customize that form with
different boxes okay or fields okay so
whatever feel they want somebody to add
information to I can have that in there
and then this form could be you know on
your website so that's a great feature
about MailChimp is it helps you build an
audience so I can add this form to my
website and anybody who fills out that
form this is going to be added to my
subscriber list that I can use for
future emails to take that a step
further I can even go from building a
form to building a landing page so here
you can see if I click on audience I can
go ahead at the bottom right here I have
an option to create a landing page so if
they click on that just like everything
else in MailChimp it's fairly easy use
I'm just going to name it test click
begin here I can choose my audience
again I can what audience do I want to
add these emails to I click begin and
I'm going to accept and here now I have
all these different templates that I can
use as a landing page so if you want to
use these landing pages to collect
emails and those emails are gonna be
added to your audience then you have a
nice selection here at your disposal
okay so here I'm just gonna choose one
you know grow my list okay this is a
landing page so I can customize it just
like I do with my email template I can
add my logo okay I can start adding
different fields here like an image I
can drop an image here okay I can go
ahead
and you know drop in my social shares
okay I can drop in a box text box okay
and then I can start customizing it with
some text some imagery you know some
other information again this is a
landing page that I can then add to my
website and so anytime somebody goes to
the landing page and fills out their
email address and hit subscribe it's
going to be added to that audience list
and then I can turn around and send an
email using one of melt shifts templates
to that audience
so MailChimp really does a great job of
allowing you to grow your list within
your own website via a landing page a
form submission or or form or pop-up so
there are lots of different options
available to us so I'm going to click
Save and close here and now this landing
page is available to me so I can
customize the URL I can edit the
audience that these emails go to I can
add a page title again I can edit the
design so I can really make this an
integrated part of my website by
designing it so it fits the feel and
look of my website I can add a specific
URL and I can add a nice page title to
it so male shep again does a great job
of just making it so easy for you to
build out a landing page for you to use
on your website to collect email
addresses so if you're doing a
pay-per-click campaign on Facebook or
Google you can actually drive traffic to
these landing pages and get people to
fill out a form submission and when they
fill out the form submission that email
address is gonna get added to your
audience that's an option or you could
just add it as part of your website and
people who go there from say organic
search can find that page and add their
email address organically so that's a
great thing about the audience feature
in MailChimp and that not only can you
select an email template but you have
options to grow your audience okay again
importing contacts you could simply just
add contacts you can add you know a form
submission via pop-up or regular form
fields to your website or you can add a
landing page so it's important to note
that in MailChimp if you go to the
content studio that's where you're gonna
find all the files that you have
added to all your templates or landing
pages that you use before so if I click
on content studio here here you can see
the files I've added to my templates if
you have products you can add your
products here okay so if you have an
e-commerce store you can certainly add
your products and then those products
can be used on your landing page or your
email templates just something called a
giffy you can insert these into any of
your emails make it fun exciting
engaging here you have Instagram
so what you can do is you can integrate
you know any one of your Instagram
accounts if you have multiple accounts
or via one Instagram account you can
integrate that one Instagram account and
with your MailChimp account and when you
do that it's going to pull in all the
images that you've had on Instagram and
then you have an opportunity here just
to add a logo okay so you can use any of
your Instagram images within your emails
use one of these cool gift these again
you can import your products that you
can use for email templates or just keep
tabs and all the files that you've added
before just by clicking on my files now
when you get to the point of building
different audience lists and sending
down emails you're gonna have the option
to look at reporting to see how those
emails perform for those specific
audiences now again an audience is a set
it's like a segment you know these are
set of individuals who are gonna receive
a specific email so in this example you
can see I have different audiences and
if we look at say any one of these
audience or even just go to all
audiences we'll be able to see how we
fared on some of our emails okay so for
example if I send out an email here in
April and this is April of 2019 I could
see how many total subscribers I've had
now along with the number of subscribers
you have you have what we call open rate
and click-through rate now we explain a
lot of the reporting and the specific
email metrics and another recording that
we did last week so if you're interested
in learning more about some of the
metrics then check out the video then we
have on YouTube email marketing tutorial
we recorded this last week go into
details about all the different metrics
you can learn about with email marketing
so take a look at this video
email marketing tutorial it'll be a nice
precursor to the MailChimp tutorial so
to give you some insights as to what
metrics to really pay attention to with
email marketing but in MailChimp we know
we can look at the total number of
subscribers we know that we have how
many opens and we know what the open
rate is and again the total number of
clicks and what the click-through rate
is okay so with MailChimp very easily
you just hover over it you get the raw
number and then the percentage so open
rate is how many people actually open
that email based on the total number of
people that the email was sent to so
here we can see in this particular email
last year in April you know we've had 14
percent 14 1.1 percent to be exact and
that is 13375 69 so that's how many
people open the email to 13 thousand out
of 97 is about 14 percent now when
somebody opens it we hope they're going
to click on it and so here we got a 1.4
percent click-through rate again that's
the total number of clicks based on the
total number of subscribers or people
that were sent the email
and so MailChimp just gives you a nice
overview of how many subscribers were in
this particular audience list and then
the open rating click rate so we can
really dive in here and we can actually
see how the particular email perform so
we just pick one email here we can just
click view report we have other options
here we can print we can download we can
share it the whole campaign or just view
the email if we want to view what the
email look like we just select that so
we just want to view the report so we're
going to click view report and now we
can get into some nice detailed
information about the actual report
itself so again here you can see total
number of recipients and this came from
the audience list called newsletter okay
was delivered last year September 26
2008
again I have the option to view it
download it print it or share it so
let's take a look and view the email to
see what it looked like ok so this is
what the email look like we have our own
template here and here you can see it
takes into account some of the best
practices involved with email marketing
you know we have some nice content
imagery call-to-action here some other
links ok we have our social icons and so
that's what the email look like ok so
we'll go back and we're going to click
view report now we want to view the
report again here's what it looked
here's when it was sent
ok the open rate for this was 21%
click-through rate was 4% so for us the
list average this list here newsletter
the average was for the open rate 16.8%
so we're above the average on this email
for the click-through rate the list
average is 2 point 7 so we're above the
average so we've done a good job on this
email at least generating more opens
more clicks and MailChimp even takes
that a step further they'll even show
you what the industry average is for
your particular industry in this case
for education and training so we did
better than the industry average for
both the open rate and for the
click-through rate so we could see some
other specifics we can see the raw
numbers of opens clicks how many people
bounce meaning the email address wasn't
valid anymore and so MailChimp does a
good job of any email that actually
bounces it'll be scrubbed and removed
from your list and then here you can see
347 unsubscribe so the thing about you
know MailChimp is we want to be careful
we don't have too many on subscribes and
also people abusing or reporting abuse
meaning you don't want to send out an
email multiple multiple times a week
where it gets the point where it's
spamming and so you want to avoid a high
number of unsubscribes and a high number
of abuse reports and so here you can see
most emails are open within a 24 hour
period and then it kind of just tails
off so here we can see opens and clicks
based on the time of day so within a 24
hour period ok so this is how most
emails operate within that first 24
hours you're going to get a lot of opens
a lot of clicks and then it's
to tell from there great thing is
MailChimp provides me more detailed
information about what was clicked so I
could see here the top links that were
clicked and let me just point one thing
out here whether you use MailChimp or
you use any other platform whether that
be vertical response or any other type
of email marketing platform you want to
use you team tracking with your links so
that Google Analytics can pick up the
actual campaign so here you can see we
have UTM tracking appended to our links
and let me just go in to detail on that
for just a minute so MailChimp again
gives us nice data on open and
click-through rates well when we sent
out an email and people actually do
click on one of these links they're
going to go to our website and from
there Google Analytics is going to take
over on the tracking so this is as far
as MailChimp goes so we want to be able
to bridge the gap between MailChimp
reporting and Google Analytics meaning
when they came from the animal email
went and went to the site did they
convert meaning did they download
something did they purchase something
and so we want to be able to bridge the
gap and UTM tracking which is simply
appending the original URL with some
tracking parameters named UTM it allows
us to bridge that gap so all you need to
do when you set up a MailChimp campaign
is just go to URL builder in Google then
you're gonna click on campaign URL
builder and we're gonna go ahead and set
up an email campaign so for example if
we go back here this was the original
URL so if I just copy this original URL
here and paste that as part of my
website URL what's my campaign source
I'm gonna put MailChimp what's my medium
I'm gonna put email so MailChimp is the
source of where the traffic came from
the medium the means in which they
arrived at our web site was via email
into the campaign name we're just gonna
put maybe whatever it is summer promo so
with the URL builder you have five
parameters for you team tracking you
have to use all five okay so here we
need to put in the URL and we need to
put in the source but the other four
parameters medium named term and content
are optional so you don't have to put
anything there but the more parameters
you put in the more specific it is for
you to track the behavior of that email
campaign so here I can see MailChimp
emails summer promo and then for the
content I can use that to differentiate
my subject lines so when you send out an
email we mentioned this in the email
marketing tutorial you always want to
send out multiple subject lines meaning
one list gets one subject line another
list gets the second subject line
because you want to be able to measure
open rates based on subject lines so I
can use the campaign content parameter
for different subject lines and notice
the URL builder once I enter in my
parameters it's going to append the
original URL with a new URL a pendant
with UTM tracking so if I copy that I
can simply just paste that in my browser
just to see if it works and here you can
see it works the page loaded the
original URL with UTM tracking and so
that's exactly what you want to do
because when you're looking at your
reports in MailChimp it's going to show
me the top links that were clicked now
if I go in analytics I want to be able
to see how that campaign or how that
link actually performed so let's take a
look at that real quick so if I go to my
Google Analytics account and I go to
acquisition campaigns all campaigns what
am I looking for well if I click on
source and medium source and medium or
to the parameters for UTM tracking I'm
gonna look for MailChimp so here I could
see I'm originally URL MailChimp and
then the date stamp and then the mediums
email so if I go back here I can see for
example any one of these meal champ
emails that went out and then I can see
how many people actually came from the
email what the bounce rate was meaning
if they arrived on the side did they
leave after arriving or they they
actually go to another page and then I
can see other engagement data like how
many pages they look
did they how much time do they spend
more importantly did they convert so
that's the whole idea behind using UTM
tracking because with you team tracking
you can can bridge the gap from open
rate click their way to behavior on the
website all the way through to the
conversion and that's what we want to
measure we want to measure did somebody
go from the email open it click on one
of the links go to the website engage on
the website and convert and so that's
the whole idea behind UTM tracking
because MailChimp and any other email
marketing platform is only gonna give
you at most your open rates and your
click-through rates ok so here we can
see the top links clicked
I see 4,000 recipients clicked on this
email they went to the site and now I
need analytics to kind of tell me the
rest and here I can see what subscribers
had the most opens and if I integrate it
social I can see some social performance
and so that goes back to our original
setup so if you integrate your Twitter
account or Facebook account you'll be
able to integrate that email in with
your Twitter and then from there I'll be
able to see you know tweets or how many
likes for example and to top it all off
I can see how many people from around
the world click on the email so that's
reporting in a nutshell on MailChimp
reports are fairly easy to look at you
know all sorts of other information like
links specifically links you can look at
social so if I click on the social tab
here if I integrated my social I can
look at social reporting likewise for
e-commerce and notice the Analects 360 I
can integrate Google Analytics in with
MailChimp if I want to so I have all
sorts of options my reporting so that's
it for MailChimp I mean it's fairly easy
to navigate you have all the campaign's
that you sent out so if you just click
on campaigns I'll be able to see all the
campaigns I've set up and all the
campaigns that have been sent and
obviously the ones that have been sent I
can start looking at reports I can pick
and choose templates ok I can pick and
choose my audience and manage my
audience
I can see what the growth is from
audience can I have different options to
grow my audience okay I can certainly
add form submissions landing pages
signup forms I can import more contacts
and I can manage them through different
lists content studio is where all your
files are gonna be located from the
files you've uploaded to e-commerce
products to get these to Instagram to my
logo and then you have reports and the
reports are there for you to measure the
performance of your email campaigns once
they've been sent so you can look at
them from reports or just from the main
campaigns view that's pretty much it so
if you're ready to go at it again click
that create button click that template
choose that audience you can go ahead
and send yourself that test email when
you're ready go ahead and send that
email off to your audience it's that
simple and MailChimp so I want to thank
you for paying attention if you have any
comments feel free underneath this video
to go in and add them we'd love to hear
from you any tips and advice you have
for MailChimp feel free to share with
other subscribers to simply learn to
youtube channel we'd love to hear from
you we'll respond accordingly and we
want to thank you again for paying
attention if you need more information
please visit us at simply learn com
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here